what are you working on
oh man
how's life recently it's great when did
we see when did we do this last I feel
like close to a year ago like eight
months ago nine months ago or something
yeah it's been a whole I've had a whole
lifetime since then yeah yeah I'm in I'm
I I don't know how much I can talk about
it but I I think I can say all of the
general details which are
amazing and very cool
um but I don't want to say anything uh
conclusive because things are sort of in
the TV World things are often in the
process of being decided right I'm in
New York currently right now um no we're
in LA right now but I'm I'm I'm no we're
not on Space yeah we're in outer space
yeah which is we're in the Los Angeles
area of of space yeah exactly you can
see La though yeah it's that desert yeah
Hollywood
wow where dreams are made of this is
what you know whatever the phrase is
it's so gorgeous this this space always
reminds me of when I first put on my
Oculus my Oculus they like put you in a
space station oh yeah yeah yeah this
isn't this doesn't have anything to do
with that right no but I mean this could
be VR if you think about it yeah that's
true that's [__] true
um I'm in New York writing an FX TV show
yeah yeah which I think we talked about
maybe a little bit yeah there's a
picture I think maybe we you had
recently sold the pilot yeah yeah so
since I've seen you
we shot the pilot in Atlanta although
it's set in Austin it's about Austin but
um you know things shoot all over the
place and that went great and now we are
without saying anything we are writing
the season of the show in New York City
and that's what I've been working on for
the past couple months and I I'm still
I'm going back to work on it for another
month right now it's cool like you know
we have like a proper writer's room and
it's it's also cool because
like getting brought to New York City is
very cool like with a job you know
because New York is like such a hard
place to be and so I was always like
well I want to live in New York for a
while but I want I want to have somebody
like bring me there in a cool way where
it's like you're successful come to New
York yeah yeah yeah like come like come
be in a Broadway play or something yeah
right
um so this has been a cool experience of
that but it's also been an experience of
being like God apartments in New York
City
I mean you think La is it's just like
New York is like
all the apartments are so old and so
expensive in the way where you're like
is this a joke like it's it's just like
the the prices are like they're just
this whole other like you're like oh
this is a different world and then you
get used to it because I'm in this
apartment there
that I don't I don't like it that much
like a one bedroom it's like just for my
stay while I'm working there you know
have any like asbestos at all I have
yeah it's made out of asbestos it's from
the asbestos from the they made it out
of like couch especially okay okay yeah
I'm in this apartment yeah I don't even
like it that much where is it just it's
it's it's it's near Union Square okay
which is very Central and cool but
anyway the the point is like anybody who
lives in New York because I have friends
who live in New York
when they come over they're like this
place is a [__] Mansion they're like
this is I can't imagine yeah yeah and
I'm like this is so much smaller than
anything I've ever lived in in La you
know La just has it just has a lot more
room
so anyway New York it's tough going I
was born there actually I was born in
New York City oh really yeah I moved
away when I was like four so I like can
kind of say I'm from New York but I grew
up in I grew up in super super rural
Tennessee so it's like I went from like
the biggest city ever it's like the
smallest country town with one one um
stoplight how do you like being now in
the um you know the large Apple
I like it I feel like I don't know yeah
I got I kind of I go in and out of being
sick of it it's very exciting at first
you're like wow and you know what's cool
about New York is it's walkable like
that is a serious thing like you can
walk places
you can walk to the subway you know it's
not like it's not like you're driving
your car to like the Olive Garden you
know 30 minutes away it's like
everything's right there but but yeah it
has made me be like oh I know why people
like L.A because I can when I'm in La
for a long time I'm like ah L.A you know
everybody thinks it's so great but you
you you you you know it becomes like
family it's like you're I don't know you
have a mixed relationship to it or I do
at least but coming from New York you're
like oh my God La the sunshine the space
the parking lots you know it's
that's interesting yeah it's a funny
place to be get fired up about a parking
lot yeah exactly the sunny parking lot
where where uh I was just in New York
actually oh yes last weekend I just got
back did you do a show no but I did I
went to a show Noelle show no no no
Bruce Springsteen whoa yeah incredible
yeah it was pretty [__] crazy I
wasn't I was amazing I I didn't know
what to expect like my soap for my wife
oh my God I almost just said girlfriend
what the [__] my wife uh her last
birthday I got her and her tickets uh
her and her family tickets to go see
Bruce because they all are huge fans and
I figured like
they have family in New York uh that we
see every time we're there so I'll be
like it's a good excuse to go so we'll
do the one at Madison Square Garden
because I'd never been there and I
figured that would be like the best
place to see him right he's from the
East Coast he's from New Jersey so yeah
yeah and they were like you know ever
since then they were like schooling me
on this like this guy puts on the best
show in the world out of any musician
it's he's 73 years old he goes he does
three four hour sets non-stop no breaks
three oh three or four hours so it's
like three to four hour sets oh yeah I
thought you're saying he does three four
hour sets
um no and so I was like okay I didn't
you know I was taking all that sort of
with a grain of salt because I feel like
if you're a real fan of someone you're
like of course they put on the best show
ever yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so we
go and the show started the ticket said
it started at 7 30 and at like 7 40 him
and his whole band comes on and which is
abnormal right usually I mean usually
there's like an opener yeah yeah exactly
like nine in place till 10. yeah yeah
yeah which I always hate I want them to
just come out and do the show I I yeah I
I agree with that I think I'm of the
opinion that a perfect the perfect
length of a concert is 35 minutes yeah
exactly like play
four to five of your best Tunes uh let
me go home you're speaking my language I
can't I don't go to concerts because
they're so far from that they're like do
you want to be here for the next four
hours yeah yes it's like no but and
you're like freezing if you're at the
Hollywood Bowl it's like yeah yeah it's
9 00 p.m in the desert yeah this was the
first one though where I was like I
didn't want it to end yeah hell yeah and
at two hours they so he like literally
it's like they don't even he doesn't
even talk they start playing music wow
and then they'll do like you know their
songs you're like he doesn't even sing
he's not even there uh
is like long ass outro to a song where
it'll be like you know that did the
drummers going like this on the symbols
two three four right into the next song
for [__] two hours straight and then
at two hours they all walk to the front
of the stage as if they're gonna like
Take a Bow the lights go on and so we're
like oh okay it's over and they're like
thank you New York and then they just go
back to the instruments and play for
another hour whoa
and then and then finally the show
finally ends
which again I was like I didn't want it
to end but like three hours it's like
okay it's gotta end sometime right and
the whole thing at all during the show
uh I took I think I took one p okay yes
um you know I saw a meal there actually
oh he's a Bruce and Phil yeah I know
they were like sitting right by us oh no
way yeah it's kind of kind of bizarre
yeah if I was on a three-hour show I
would have peed like ten times I gotta
get my bladder checked or something are
you good yeah it'll be fun
but yeah I was just like three hours and
I was like damn dude is that how you
measure me yeah you probably get checked
out of your measuring I know yeah yeah I
always got time but I also just drink a
lot of liquid you see I got the Evian
yeah you've been going hard I know I
know I always get an aisle seat on a
plane and if I don't if I if I have to
get a window I'm like I feel bad for the
person at that point when you sit down I
don't and then I'm just like you know
what they're an adult they can deal with
how many times
but you don't tell them to move you just
go like this yeah yeah on top of them
yes and I kiss him on the floor random
people you know sorry you don't you
don't have to get up I gotta go pee and
this is my issue so let me just climb on
me like that yeah exactly it always is a
debate they're like should I get up or
should because then because it's so
funny to make an adult like do like that
and you do yeah you're like yeah do that
no don't get up yeah and they're like oh
I'm fine I'd rather get up actually I'd
rather get up and do this crazy move
yeah contort your body yeah for me to
squeeze by wait what are some of Bruce
Springsteen's um Let me let me see is
let me can I see a list of his hits oh
my God I mean it's I know I know them
but when it's like I want to just
imagine this and then so but at the end
of the three hours the band
they all they finally they all like you
know he he so and so on the sacks so and
so on the band is like the E Street Band
it's like 12 people yeah and they all
okay finally take this big Crescendo to
end the show and then all the band
members Bruce walks each one down the
stairs back into the green room and then
he comes back out
puts on a harmonica and does like a
final song just by himself wow which I
thought was kind of funny because it's
kind of like a
like do you think his band is like [__]
you man yeah they're like Bruce you
gotta go up there and do one more song
by yourself yeah like they don't love
you enough yeah yeah
um I'm on fire incredible Dancing in the
Dark incredible
see the Streets of Philadelphia born in
the USA oh Born in the USA Glory Days so
good yeah
um
Hungry Heart so good you know what's
crazy is they turn on the lights
and everyone starts looking over the
right and are like what and they look at
Paul McCartney's right there Hamming the
[__] out and then Adam Scott is right
beside him and then Ben Stiller is right
beside him and then I saw Keith from
Kian peel whoa that's the Beatles now as
those four guys
that's the new that's the 2023 Beatles